This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedant. Some months ago, I brought seven key insights from the first decade of Hidden Brain to live stage performances in San Francisco and Seattle. The evenings were electric. Electric. We got so much positive feedback from those two sold out shows that we've decided to launch a tour to more than a dozen cities in the coming months. I'll be coming to Portland, Denver, Minneapolis, Chicago, Austin, Dallas, Boston, Toronto, Clearwater, Fort Lauderdale, Phoenix, Baltimore, Washington, D.C., and Los Angeles. To snap up your tickets, please go to hiddenbrain.org slash tour.
这里是隐藏的大脑。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。几个月前，我将关于“隐藏的大脑”发展头十年的七个核心见解带到了旧金山和西雅图的现场表演中。当晚的气氛简直太棒了。太棒了。那两场门票售罄的演出收获了大量积极的反馈，因此我们决定在接下来的几个月里启动一个涵盖十多个城市的巡演。我将去往波特兰、丹佛、明尼阿波利斯、芝加哥、奥斯汀、达拉斯、波士顿、多伦多、克利尔沃特、劳德代尔堡、菲尼克斯、巴尔的摩、华盛顿特区以及洛杉矶。要想抢购门票，请访问 hiddenbrain.org 斜杠 tour。
You can also sign up to say hello and get a photo with me. In some places, you can sign up for an intimate chat with me and a handful of other fans. I'd love to see you there. Again, go to hiddenbrain.org slash tour. Okay, on to today's show. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. The 19th century naturalist and biologist Charles Darwin is best known for developing the theory of evolution by natural selection. He described the theory in his book, On the Origin of Species, one of the most important publications in the history of science.
你还可以注册报名来打个招呼并和我合影。在某些地方，你可以报名参加我和其他少数粉丝的亲密交流。我很期待在那里见到你们。再说一次，请访问 hiddenbrain.org 斜杠 tour。好了，进入今天的节目。这里是隐藏的大脑。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。19世纪的博物学家兼生物学家查尔斯·达尔文最著名的成就是提出了自然选择进化论。他在自己的著作《物种起源》中详细阐述了这一理论，这是科学史上最重要的出版物之一。
Less well known, but also scientifically important, was the biologist's research on emotions. Charles Darwin's view, which has since been adopted by contemporary scientists of emotion, is that our feelings are adaptations that help us survive and thrive in a complex world. Fear guides us to avoid things that can do us harm. Anger girds us for battle and conflict. Love pulls us toward mates, family and friends. But if emotions are so useful, why do they so often seem to get us in trouble? Why do we lose our cool and yell at our kids or mope around for weeks following a professional disappointment? Why do we lie awake at night worrying about some imagined catastrophe?
这位生物学家对情绪的研究虽然不那么知名，但在科学上也同样重要。查尔斯·达尔文的观点——后来被当代情绪科学家所采纳——是我们的感受乃是帮助我们在复杂世界中生存和繁衍的适应机制。恐惧引导我们避开能对我们造成伤害的事物。愤怒为我们的战斗和冲突蓄积力量。爱将我们拉向伴侣、家人和朋友。但如果情绪如此有用，为什么它们又似乎经常让我们陷入麻烦？为什么我们会失去冷静，对孩子大吼大叫，或者在遭遇职业挫折后一连消沉好几周？为什么我们会在夜里辗转反侧，为某个想象中的灾难忧心忡忡？
How is it we get carried away when everyone around us is losing their heads and lose ours too? Most important of all, when we do get swept away by our emotions, how should we get back on track? Today on the show, we look at the growing and fascinating science of managing our emotions. What scientists call emotion regulation turns out to be one of the most important life skills we can possess. This skill is essential in dealing with setbacks, in balancing risks and rewards, in maintaining successful relationships. Harnessing our feelings.
为什么当周围所有人都失去理智时，我们也会随之情绪失控？最重要的是，当我们真正被情绪吞没时，我们该如何重回正轨？今天的节目中，我们将探讨日益引人入胜的情绪管理科学。科学家所称的“情绪调节”被证明是我们拥有的最重要的生活技能之一。这项技能对于应对挫折、平衡风险与回报、维持成功的人际关系至关重要。驾驭我们的感受。
This week on Hidden Brain. All of us can recall moments when we acted in ways that made us feel ashamed afterwards. When we look back at these moments with a clear head, we cannot for the life of us understand why we got so angry or greedy or frightened. At the University of Michigan, psychologist Ethan Cross studies the science of emotions and techniques to help us manage them. Ethan Cross, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thanks for having me. It's a delight to be here.
本周的“隐藏的大脑”。我们所有人都能想起一些时刻，当时的行为让我们事后感到羞愧。当我们头脑清醒地回顾这些时刻时，我们无论如何也无法理解自己当时为什么会那么愤怒、贪婪或惊恐。在密歇根大学，心理学家伊森·克罗斯专门研究情绪科学以及帮助我们管理情绪的技术。伊森·克罗斯，欢迎来到“隐藏的大脑”。谢谢邀请我来。很高兴能来到这里。
Ethan, when you were growing up, your dad was someone who would regularly sit in the lotus position and practice meditation. He was a calm, patient, and sensitive man. But there was one situation that would transform him into someone completely different. What was one situation that would transform him into someone completely different. What was the situation? The situation was driving on the roads of Brooklyn, New York. He would often transform into, I have a mental image of Mad Max, if you're familiar with those movies. And he wasn't just a reckless driver right out of the driveway, but if he perceived
伊森，当你成长的时候，你的父亲经常盘腿打坐练习冥想。他是一个沉着、有耐心且敏感的人。但有一种情况会把他变成一个完全不同的人。这种情况是什么？这种情况是什么？这种情况就是开车行驶在纽约布鲁克林的道路上。他经常会变成——如果你熟悉那些电影的话，我脑海中浮现出的就是“疯狂的麦克斯”。他不只是在驶离车道时是个鲁莽的司机，但凡他察觉到
any quote unquote injustice on the road, that is another car that was driving recklessly or you know, cut someone else off, he would take it upon himself to discipline that driver. And what I mean by that is he would get in front of them and then slow our car down so that the other driver would have to slow down. If I close my eyes right now, I can see us driving on the Belt Parkway, which is this freeway that wrapped around the perimeter of Brooklyn.
路上的任何所谓“不公”，也就是说有另一辆车开得很鲁莽，或者你知道的，强行并道超车，他就会主动去“管教”那个司机。我的意思是他会开到那些人前面，然后把我们的车速慢下来，好让另一个司机也不得不减速。如果我现在闭上眼睛，我还能看到我们行驶在贝尔特公园大道上，那是环绕布鲁克林外围的一条高速公路。
And I could see him weaving in and out of cars to find the perpetrator. Yeah, I mean he was almost playing a cop without wearing a uniform except he wasn't tailing people and getting them to slow down. He was pulling in front of them and hitting the brakes. He did the tailing too, so you know, the whole nine yards. But yes, that's exactly right. You know, that was one of the first observations I had of this idea that you could be really good
我能看到他在车流中穿梭，寻找那个“肇事者”。是的，我的意思是，他几乎没穿制服就在扮演警察，只不过他不是尾随别人让人家减速，而是直接别到人家前面去踩刹车。他也会尾随，所以可以说是全套流程。不过是的，完全正确。你知道，这是我最早观察到的一个想法，即你可以在某些情况下非常擅长
at regulating your emotions in some contexts, but really bad in others. ["The Last Supper"] So as you became a teenager, you yourself experienced your own extremes of emotion. You were unflappable on the soccer field, for example, but other situations would tie you up in knots? So, when I had crushes on girls in high school, it took a while for me to ask them out on dates. And I remember many false starts, you know, starting to dial their numbers when we used to have, believe it or not, rotary phones.
调节情绪，但在另一些情况下却一塌糊涂。[《最后的晚餐》] 所以当你成为一名青少年时，你自己也经历了情绪的极端波动。例如，你在足球场上镇定自若，但其他情况却会让你纠结万分？所以，当我在高中暗恋女孩子时，我花了很长时间才敢约她们出去约会。我记得有很多次失败的尝试，你知道，开始拨打她们的电话号码——当时我们用的还是，信不信由你，转盘式电话。
And I would turn the dial, you know, turn a three number, I'd get three numbers deep and then hang it up. And then I'd go four and then I'd hang it up. And then I'd give it a rest for a day or two and have to have pep talks with my dad, for example, and some of my best friends in high school would give me pep talks to kind of build my confidence to ultimately dial the damn number and start the conversation, which I eventually did and was grateful for those pep talks. But again, it just goes to show you, I think it's really easy for us to say,
我会转动拨盘，转到第三个数字，当拨到第三个数字时我就把电话挂断了。然后我会拨到第四个，接着又挂断。然后我会歇上一两天，比方说，需要找我父亲做心理建设，我在高中的几个最好的朋友也会给我做心理建设，来帮我建立信心，好最终拨通那个该死的号码并开始对话——我最终确实这么做了，也很感激那些心理建设。但话说回来，这恰恰向你表明，我认为我们非常容易去说：
oh, that person, they're really good at managing their emotions or they're really bad. But when you get into a person's life, you see that there's always nuance. So you became a researcher who studies emotions and emotion regulation, but even all of that expertise went out the window on one occasion at the airport when you felt someone was behaving out of line.
“哦，那个人，他们真的很擅长管理自己的情绪，或者他们真的很糟糕。”但当你真正走入一个人的生活时，你会发现其中总是存在着微妙的差别。所以你成了一名研究情绪和情绪调节的研究人员，但甚至所有这些专业知识在机场的一次经历中也抛到了九霄云外，当时你觉得有个人的行为越界了。
Paint me a picture of what happened, Ethan. So this was very early in my career, and I was with my family, both my wife and daughter, one daughter at the time, and my extended family as well. We were all going on a vacation for for the winter break. The airport was jam-packed and we had dutifully waited our turn to get to the check-in counter and there was a very pleasant woman working there and she begins to check us in and then I begin to hear behind me this kerfuffle and all of a sudden this guy just has this outburst and he starts shouting at the woman who's helping us and doing her very best to deal with these enormous crowds.
给我描绘一下当时发生了什么，伊森。所以那是我的职业生涯早期，我和家人在一起，包括我的妻子和女儿（当时只有一个女儿），还有我的大家庭。我们正准备去过冬假。机场人山人海，我们循规蹈矩地排队等待走到登记柜台前，那里有一位非常亲切的女工作人员，她开始为我们办理登机手续，然后我开始听到身后传来一阵骚动，突然之间，这个家伙情绪大爆发，开始冲着那位正在极力应付庞大人群、为我们提供帮助的女士大喊大叫。
And this person's saying how he's gonna miss his flight, and this is ridiculous, and the woman is trying to calm him down. And then he says something to the effect of, I don't have to calm down. I have, that's why I bought a business class class ticket or that's why I have airline status. I forget which of the two he uttered. And the moment that I heard that, a tripwire was crossed in my brain and I turned around and I said things to him that were very confrontational.
这个人说他要赶不上航班了，这太荒谬了，女士则试图让他冷静下来。然后他说了一些类似“我不需要冷静。我有，这就是为什么我买了一张商务舱机票，或者这就是为什么我有航空公司会员身份”之类的话。我记不清他具体说的是这两者中的哪一个。当我听到这话的那一刻，我脑子里的一根导线被触发了，我转过身去，对他说了一些非常具有对抗性的话。
The moment the words came out of my mouth, I felt ashamed of saying them. And then interestingly, I remember turning around and seeing my wife and the other members of my family who were nearby, you know, moving away from me, ever so gently, I could see that they were so uncomfortable from my behavior. And you know, it's interesting to think about that incident in light of the early experiences with my dad that I mentioned to you before. In a certain sense, it was a similar dynamic. There was this perception of injustice that automatically led to an emotional hijacking, if you will. So a few years ago, millions of people were watching the
这些话刚一出口，我就为自己说出这些话感到羞愧。然后有趣的是，我记得自己转过身，看到附近的妻子和家里的其他成员，你知道的，正极其轻柔地离我远去，我能看出我的行为让他们感到多么不自在。而且，你知道，结合我之前向你提到的我父亲早年经历来思考那次事件很有意思。从某种意义上说，这是一种相似的动态。那种对“不公”的感知自动引发了一场情绪“劫持”。所以几年前，数百万人在观看
Academy Awards. The host Chris Rock made a joke that upset the actor Will Smith. For the handful of people on the planet who don't know, can you recount what happened next, Ethan? Will Smith gets out of his seat, walks relatively patiently right up to Chris Rock, and then winds up and slaps him in the face powerfully in front of everyone there and everyone who's watching. Oh wow! Wow! Will Smith just smacked the **** out of me.
奥斯卡颁奖典礼。主持人克里斯·洛克开了一个玩笑，惹怒了演员威尔·史密斯。对于地球上少数不知道的人，你能回顾一下接下来发生了什么吗，伊森？威尔·史密斯从座位上站起来，相对平静地径直走向克里斯·洛克，接着蓄力狠狠地扇了他一记耳光，当着现场所有人以及所有电视观众的面。哦，哇！哇！威尔·史密斯刚刚狠狠地抽了我一巴掌。
And then he turns around and goes and sits back down in his chair. Keep my wife's name out your **** mouth! I'm going to, okay? Greatest night in the history of television. And in that moment, we witnessed a remarkable takeover of emotion that led this, at the time, esteemed actor, Hollywood royalty to to do something that his career still hasn't recovered from many years later. I mean Will Smith ended up winning the Oscar for best actor you know a few minutes after this incident and it was presumably one of the most important highlights of his life but
然后他转过身，走回自己的椅子上坐下。别用你的脏嘴提我老婆的名字！我要说，好吗？电视史上最伟大的一夜。在那一刻，我们目睹了一场惊人的情绪失控，这导致这位当时备受尊崇的演员、好莱坞的代表人物做出了一件让他的事业在多年后仍未恢复的事。我的意思是，威尔·史密斯在这起事件发生几分钟后最终赢得了奥斯卡最佳男主角奖，这本该是他人生中最重要的高光时刻之一，但
what he had done to Chris Rock seconds earlier upstaged this important moment. Powerfully upstaged the moment. For anyone who was watching, it was just unbelievable to see someone do this. In fact, many people, myself included, initially thought that this was something that was rehearsed. He didn't really do this, because who would do such a thing? So Ethan, emotions are supposed to be really valuable to us. They're supposed to provide us with useful signals about how to act in the world.
他在几秒钟前对克里斯·洛克所做的事情，完全盖过了这个重要的时刻。强烈地盖过了这个时刻。对于任何观看直播的人来说，看到有人做出这种事简直令人难以置信。事实上，许多人（包括我自己）最初以为这是彩排好的。他不可能真的这么干，因为谁会做出这种事呢？所以伊森，情绪本该对我们非常有价值。它们本该为我们提供关于如何在世界上行事的有用信号。
So why do they sometimes cause us to say and do things that we will come to regret? Because they're what I call unwieldy tools. All of the emotions we experience, when we experience them in the right proportions, are useful. Anger, when experienced not too intensely or not too long, can be valuable. The problem that we all struggle with,
那为什么它们有时会促使我们说出和做出让我们日后会后悔的事情呢？因为它们是我所说的“笨重的工具”。我们体验到的所有情绪，当我们在恰当的比例下体验它们时，都是有用的。愤怒，如果体验得不是太强烈、时间不是太长，也可以是有价值的。我们所有人都在与之挣扎的问题是——
and this is what I call an ancient problem, this has been something that we've been struggling with for likely as long as we've been roaming the planet in our present form, is that often these emotions are triggered and they're not triggered in the right proportions. They are triggered either too intensely or not intensely enough, or they last too long or not long enough. And what I find so fascinating about us, about human beings, is guess what we also evolved? Tools to rein those emotional responses in so that if and when we are triggered we can very quickly rein those emotional responses in to help us reach whatever emotion regulatory goals we have. When we come back, when emotions go astray, insights into how to reel them
这也是我所说的一个古老的问题，自从我们以目前的形式在地球上漫步以来，我们可能就一直在与这个问题做斗争——那就是这些情绪经常被触发，而且触发的比例并不恰当。它们的触发要么过于强烈，要么不够强烈，或者持续时间太长或太短。关于我们人类，我觉得最吸引人的是，你猜我们还进化出了什么？那就是能够控制这些情绪反应的工具，这样当且仅当我们被触发时，我们可以非常迅速地重新控制这些情绪反应，以帮助我们达成我们拥有的任何情绪调节目标。广告回来后，当情绪误入歧途时，关于如何将其重新收回的见解。
back in. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Think back to moments in your life when your emotions carried you away. Perhaps you lost your temper over a disputed parking spot. Maybe a colleague set you off at work. Or a small dispute with a partner ended up with shouting and tears. Often when we look back on these moments, we cannot for the life of us understand how we could have been so short-sighted. Sometimes the consequences of our words and actions stay with us for years, even lifetimes.
你正在收听的是“隐藏的大脑”。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是隐藏的大脑。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。回想一下你生活中情绪失控的时刻。也许你为了一个争执不下的停车位大发雷霆。也许某个同事在工作惹恼了你。或者与伴侣的一次小争吵最终以大喊大叫和眼泪收场。通常，当我们回顾这些时刻时，我们无论如何也无法理解自己当时怎么会如此短视。有时，我们言行带来的后果会伴随我们多年，甚至一生。
Psychologist Ethan Cross studies our emotions and how they often get the better of us. He's thought a lot about how we can get a handle on our feelings. Ethan, you tell the remarkable story of an astronaut who had to confront a runaway train of his own emotions in one of the most dangerous situations possible. Set the scene, tell me his story. So this is a story of Jerry Lininger who was working on the Mir space station and he's doing some data entry when all of a sudden he begins to hear the space station alarms begin to siren. He stops entering the data and goes to investigate.
心理学家伊森·克罗斯研究我们的情绪以及它们如何经常让我们失去理智。他深入思考了我们如何才能掌控自己的感受。伊森，你讲过一个非凡的故事，讲的是一位宇航员在极度危险的情况下，不得不对抗自己失控的情绪。请还原当时的场景，给我们讲讲他的故事。这是一个关于杰里·林宁格的故事，当时他在和平号空间站工作，正在录入一些数据，突然之间，他听到空间站的警报器开始拉响。他停下手中的数据录入工作，前去查看。
And as he moves down the portal and turns around the the corner, he begins to see fire and smoke. corner, he begins to see fire and smoke. His first instinct is to go find a respirator. So he begins to swim through the air, trying to find a respirator. And as he's swimming through the air, trying to find this respirator, all sorts of random thoughts begin to fire in his mind, some of which are quite irrational, for example. One thought was open a window,
当他穿过舱门转过墙角时，他开始看到火苗和浓烟。墙角，他开始看到火苗和浓烟。他的第一本能是去找一个防毒面具。于是他开始在空中游动，试图寻找防毒面具。正当他在空中游动、寻找这个防毒面具时，各种各样的随机想法开始在他的脑海中闪现，其中有一些相当不理性，比如。其中一个想法是打开一窗户，
not something that you either can do or want to do in outer space. Just an example of how the mind is cycling through these different potential solutions to the problems we're in. So he keeps on looking for a respirator, he finds one and then it begins to malfunction. And at this point, the space station is filling with smoke, he's having trouble breathing, and he's really beginning to worry about his survival, he's thinking about his wife and child back on planet Earth. And as he's beginning to search for that respirator, he actually starts talking to himself like he's giving advice to someone else. He says to
这并不是你在太空中能够或想要做的事情。这只是大脑如何在面对我们身处的问题时，在各种潜在解决方案之间循环往复的一个例子。于是他继续寻找防毒面具，找到了一个，然后它开始发生故障。此时，空间站里充满了浓烟，他呼吸困难，他真的开始担心自己的生存，他想起了远在地球上的妻子和孩子。正当他开始搜寻那个防毒面具时，他实际上开始对自己说话，就像是在给别人提建议一样。他对
himself, okay Jerry, you've got to get going. You need oxygen here. You need to start acting. And he just manages to go a tiny bit further and find one more respirator and he puts it on, it's working, and then he begins to put out the fire. One extinguisher after another after another. Eventually the fire gets under control, they extinguish it, they put it out. The fire on the space station goes down
自己说：“好了，杰里，你得动起来了。这里需要氧气。你得开始行动了。”他勉强再往前挪了一点点，找到了最后一个防毒面具，他把它戴上，它起作用了，然后他开始扑灭大火。一个灭火器接着一个，又接着一个。最终火势得到了控制，他们将其扑灭。空间站上的这场火灾被记载为
as one of the worst catastrophes in space travel history, and he lives to tell the story of what happened after. and he lives to tell the story of what happened after. So you've run multiple studies that explore the power of what Jerry did that day on the spacecraft. He talked to himself, he coached himself through the crisis. You've looked at something called distanced self-talk. What is this, Ethan, and what do you find? What distant self-talk involves is coaching yourself through a problem, typically silently,
太空旅行史上最严重的灾难之一，而他活了下来，讲述了之后发生的事情。而他活了下来，讲述了之后发生的事情。所以你做过多项研究，探索了杰里那天在太空舱里所做事情的力量。他对自己说话，在危机中通过自我指导来度过难关。你研究过一种叫做“距离化自我对话”的东西。伊森，这是什么，你有什么发现？所谓的“距离化自我对话”，是指通过解决一个问题来进行自我指导，通常是默默地进行，
using your name or you to give yourself instruction. You're essentially talking to yourself in your head like you would give advice to someone else. One of the things we know about people is that it is often much easier for us to give advice to others than it is to take our own advice. There's the famous saying, do as I say, not as I do. And what we see happening across studies is that when you ask people to try to navigate intense negative emotional experiences, it's a lot easier for them to do so effectively when they're using this kind of self-talk.
使用你的名字或者“你”来给自己下达指令。你基本上是在脑海中对自己说话，就像你会给别人提建议一样。关于人类，我们了解的一件事是，我们常常给别人提建议要比听取自己的建议容易得多。有句名言叫“照我说的做，不要照我做的做”。我们在各项研究中看到的是，当你要求人们试着应对强烈负面情绪体验时，如果他们使用这种自我对话，就会容易得多，并且能有效地做到这一点。
We find that it not only helps people calm down subjectively, it also helps them reason more wisely about their problems. They're able to look at the bigger picture, they're able to recognize the limits of their own knowledge, predict multiple ways that the future might develop. Ethan says that one of his favorite examples of someone using this technique can be heard in a clip of Nobel Peace Prize winner Malala Yousafzai. She was doing an interview on The Daily Show with Jon Stewart,
我们发现它不仅能帮助人们主观上冷静下来，还能帮助他们更明智地推理自己的问题。他们能够着眼于更宏大的格局，能够认识到自身知识的局限性，并预测未来的多种可能发展。伊森说，他最喜欢的使用这种技术的例子之一可以在诺贝尔和平奖得主马拉拉·优素福扎伊的一段视频剪辑中听到。她当时在接受乔恩·斯图尔特主持的《每日秀》采访，
and he asked her to tell the audience what was going through her head when she discovered that the Taliban were plotting to kill her for the advocacy work she was doing for the rights of young girls to receive an education. And she then goes on to narrate her inner monologue. And she starts off by saying, you know, I used to think to myself, what would I do if the Tali would come and kill me? And then she says, but then I said, if he comes, what would you do, Malala? But then I would reply to myself and say, if he comes, what would you do, Malala? So it seems there's some internal radar that guides some of us to use this tool automatically
乔恩请她告诉观众，当她发现塔利班正密谋杀害她时，她脑子里在想什么——当时她正积极为年轻女孩接受教育的权利奔走呼吁。接着她开始讲述自己的内心独白。她一开始说，你知道的，我曾经对自己说：“如果塔利班来杀我，我会怎么做？”然后她说：“但接着我对说，如果他来了，你会怎么做，马拉拉？”接着我会在心里回答自己说：“如果他来了，你会怎么做，马拉拉？”因此，似乎存在某种内在的雷达，当我们在生活中饱受煎熬时，它会引导我们中的一些人自动使用这个工具。
when we're really struggling with our experiences. And what we've learned from the research is that you don't have to wait to just spontaneously slide into that way of talking to yourself, likely without any conscious awareness of the fact that you're doing that. You can actually be a lot more strategic in using this type of self-talk in your own life
而我们从研究中了解到的是，你没必要非得等到自己无意识地、毫无察觉地滑入那种对自己说话的方式。你实际上可以更具战略性地在自己的生活中使用这种类型的自我对话，
to help you deal with your emotions. I understand the tennis star Novak Djokovic also knows about this technique. Describe how he used it at Wimbledon in 2022. So it was early in the Wimbledon tournament and he's playing a much, much lower ranked opponent and he's getting creamed in the match. He's really doing poorly.
来帮助你处理自己的情绪。我听说网球明星诺瓦克·德约科维奇也知道这项技术。请描述一下他在2022年温网公开赛上是如何使用它的。那是温网公开赛的早期阶段，他正在对阵一个排名低得多得多的对手，结果在比赛中被打得落花流水。他的表现真的很糟糕。
And he takes a break in the middle and he goes to the bathroom. And then when he comes out of the bathroom, he's like a different player. He proceeds to dominate the rest of the match and ultimately win. After the match is over, a journalist asks him, what happened in the bathroom? What happened that turned the match around? And he says he went to the bathroom and he gave himself a pep talk.
他在中场休息时去了洗手间。当他从洗手间出来时，他就像变了一个人。他开始主导比赛的剩余部分并最终获胜。比赛结束后，一名记者问他：“洗手间里发生了什么？发生了什么让比赛得以逆转？”他说他去了洗手间，并对自己进行了一番心理建设。
Listen to what he says as a direct quote, what he said to himself in the locker room. You can do it. Believe in yourself. Now is the time. Forget everything that has happened. New match starts now. Let's go champ."
听听他的原话，他在更衣室里对自己说了什么：“你能做到。相信自己。就是现在。忘掉过去发生的一切。新比赛现在开始。上吧，冠军。”
That's the kind of advice you would give to another person. When my friends come to me and they are experiencing self-doubt and they confess it to me, looking for support, those are precisely the things that I say to them. And I think the big question for us all to ponder is, why don't we say those kinds of things to ourselves when we're struggling? For those of us who speak more than one language, Ethan, you say that being bilingual offers an unusual way to get some distance from our emotions. How so?
这就是你会对另一个人给出的建议。当我的朋友们来找我、经历自我怀疑并向我倾诉以寻求支持时，这正是我对他们说的话。我认为我们所有人都需要认真思考的一个重大问题是：为什么我们在自己苦挣扎时，不对自己说这样的话呢？伊森，对于我们这些会说不止一种语言的人来说，你说双语提供了一种从情绪中获得一些距离的不寻常方式。怎么说呢？
So there's this interesting phenomenon where when you talk about emotional experiences in a second language, they don't seem to have the same impact. For me personally, there are two languages that I've learned later on in life, and with each one, when I've tried cursing in those languages, inevitably you learn about the expletives, and at least for me, I try them out. Saying those bad things doesn't seem quite as inappropriate as if I were to say the same expletive in English. This is a documented phenomenon so our emotions are encoded in our native language and there's deep resonance between emotions and our
这里有一个有趣的现象：当你用第二语言谈论情感体验时，它们似乎不会产生相同的影响。就我个人而言，我有两种是在晚些时候才学会的语言，每当我在这些语言中尝试说脏话时——不可避免地你会学到那些脏话，至少对我来说，我会去尝试一下。说那些不好的话似乎并不像如果我在英语中说出同样的脏话那样显得很不恰当。这是一个已被记录的现象，因此我们的情绪是被编码在我们的母语中的，
native language as a result. When you ask people to try to reason about really thorny emotional dilemmas in a second language, it allows them to do so more objectively. One idea that's related to the concept of emotional distancing has to do with something that is called expressive writing. We've touched on this previously on the show. What is expressive writing, Ethan, and what do we know about its power to help us with emotion regulation?
正因如此，情绪与我们的母语之间存在着深厚的共鸣。当你要求人们试着用第二语言来推理棘手的情感困境时，这能让他们更客观地做到这一点。一个与“情绪距离化”概念相关的想法，与一种被称为“表达性写作”的事物有关。我们在之前的节目中曾触及过这个话题。伊森，什么是表达性写作，我们对它帮助我们进行情绪调节的力量了解多少？
What expressive writing involves is sitting down and writing about your deepest thoughts and feelings about an experience you're struggling with for 15 to 20 minutes a day, for anywhere between one to three consecutive days. And the research on this tool is pretty compelling. It shows that when you ask people to engage in this form of emotion regulation, when you ask people to use this tool, it helps them feel better
表达性写作是指连续一到三天，每天花15到20分钟坐下来，写下你对正深陷其中的某种体验的最深层想法和感受。针对这个工具的研究相当令人信服。它表明，当你要求人们参与这种形式的情绪调节时，当你要求人们使用这个工具时，它能帮助他们在一段时间内对自己的经历感觉更好。
about their experiences over time. You find that they're, they're less distressed about the experience. They're healthier. They, they visit the doctors less over the next few months. The thinking here is when you sit down to write about an experience, you have to write about someone who that experience is happening to. So essentially you're thrust into this narrator role and you become a character in the story that you're writing about.
你会发现他们对这段经历的痛苦感减少了。他们更健康了。在接下来的几个月里，他们看医生的次数也变少了。这里的思考逻辑是，当你坐下来写下一段经历时，你必须写到一个正在经历这段经历的人。所以本质上，你被推入了叙事者的角色，成了你所书写的那个故事中的一个角色。
And in a set of studies we find that that has a distancing function which predicts some of the benefits linked with this tool. So some time ago, you accidentally stumbled on another powerful emotion regulation strategy. Your daughter was in a bad mood and you were on your way to a soccer game together. Paint me a picture of what happened that day, Ethan. So this was my youngest daughter, Danny,
在一系列研究中，我们发现这具有距离化的功能，它预示着与该工具相关的一些益处。不久前，你不经意间发现了另一种强大的情绪调节策略。当时你女儿心情不好，你们正一起开车去踢足球。请给我描绘一下那天发生了什么，伊森。那是我的小女儿丹妮，
and I was one of the coaches on her soccer team. The time we got to spend together on that soccer field was just priceless. I would wake up ready to go, and then one morning, Dani comes down the stairs and she's just not into it. She's moping along. I try all my dad tricks to break her out of her funk. None are effective We pile into the car. I glance in the back seat and I could see her head drooping down and I will admit it was beginning to bring me down and then a few minutes into the ride to the soccer field, a song starts playing
我是她足球队的教练之一。我们在那个足球场上共度的那段时光简直是无价之宝。我醒来时就准备好出发了，然而有一天早晨，丹妮走下楼来，却完全提不起兴致。她无精打采地拖着步子。我使出了所有当爸爸的把戏来试图让她摆脱阴郁的情绪。全无效果。我们挤进车里。我瞥了一眼后座，看到她的头耷拉下来，我得承认，这也开始让我情绪低落。然后，在去足球场的路上开了几分钟后，车载音响开始播放一首歌
over the speakers in the car, one of my favorites, Journeys Don't Stop Believing. And without really thinking about it, I just start bopping my head and singing the song. I turn the volume up a bit and I'm feeling good again. And then I look in the rear view window and I see that Danny's bopping her head too and mouthing the words along. And before you know it, I'm really leaning into this song in true dad fashion, singing it very loud, banging on the wheel as I'm doing it.
——我最喜欢的歌曲之一，杰乐队的《别放弃》。在没有多想的情况下，我开始跟着节奏晃脑袋并唱起歌来。我把音量调大了一点，我又感觉好起来了。然后我看了看后视镜，看到丹妮也开始晃脑袋，并且嘴里跟着哼唱歌词。不知不觉中，我真正地沉浸在这首歌里，摆出一副老爸的经典架势，大声歌唱，一边唱一边敲打着方向盘。
And usually she would cringe at the sight of me doing it, but for whatever reason, she was just playing along this time. And we both were just energized by the music. And fast forward a couple of minutes, we pull up to the soccer field, Dani bolts out of the car, she runs around the field, she has a great game. And what really stood out to me about that experience Danny bolts out of the car, she runs around the field, she has a great game.
通常她看到我这样做会感到尴尬，但不知为什么，这一次她居然很配合。我们俩都被音乐注入了活力。快进几分钟后，我们将车停在足球场旁，丹妮冲下车，在场上奔跑，踢了一场精彩的比赛。那次经历之后，真正让我记忆犹新的是，
And what really stood out to me about that experience after it happened was just how powerful music was for rerouting both of our emotional experiences on that morning. And now I have of course listened to music my entire life and I've enjoyed it. But up until that moment I never really thought about using music strategically as a tool to modulate how I feel. So after this experience, my colleagues and I dug into the literature on music and emotion and asked people, why do you listen to music? And almost 100% of the participants in the sample, I think the number was 96% of them, reported that they listen to music because they like the way it makes them feel.
音乐在那个早晨重塑我们双方情绪体验的力量是如此强大。当然，我听了一辈子音乐并且也很享受它。但在那一刻之前，我从没真正想过将音乐作为一种战略工具来调节我的感受。因此，在这次经历之后，我和同事们深入研究了关于音乐与情绪的文献，并询问人们：“你们为什么听音乐？”几乎样本中的所有参与者——我想这个数字是96%——都表示他们听音乐是因为他们喜欢音乐带给他们的感觉。
In other words, it's having a regulatory effect. But then when we do studies and we ask people across a series of studies, think back to the last time you were anxious or angry or sad. What did you do to manage your feelings? Only between 10 and 30% of the participants in those studies report availing themselves of this tool. Just like I, before this experience, didn't avail myself of this tool. So what we're talking about here, the light bulb that went off for me in that moment, is that our senses are powerful, powerful shifters of our emotions.
换句话说，它具有调节效应。但随后当我们进行研究，在一系列研究中询问人们：回想一下你上一次感到焦虑、愤怒或悲伤的时候。你做了什么来管理你的感受？在那些研究中，只有10%到30%的参与者报告说他们利用了这个工具。就像我在这次经历之前也没有利用这个工具一样。所以我们在这里谈论的是，我在那个时刻脑中闪现的灵光，那就是我们的感官是情绪的强大塑造者。
So you went on to more broadly study the use of senses in emotion regulation, not just sounds, but also taste and sight and smell? All of the major five senses have the potential to activate our emotions relatively effortlessly. Part of the way sensation operates is by triggering emotional responses. Sensation being the way we make sense of the world around us. Well, it makes sense that if you have the equivalent of these satellite dishes mounted all over your body that are tuned to different kinds of information, i.e. your senses, if you come across stimuli or experiences that are positive or negative, you want those senses to trigger those emotional responses to cue you to approach
所以你后来更广泛地研究了感官在情绪调节中的应用，不仅是声音，还包括味觉、视觉和嗅觉？所有这五大感官都有可能毫不费力地激活我们的情绪。感知运作的部分方式就是通过触发情绪反应。感知是我们理解周围世界的方式。嗯，这很合理，如果你身上安装了相当于对准各种信息（即你的感官）的卫星天线，如果你遇到积极或消极的刺激或体验，你会希望这些感官触发那些情绪反应，以提示你接近
or avoid those kinds of stimuli or experiences. So sensation and emotion are intimately linked. I mean, we could go down the list. We just talked about music. Music can push our emotions around in all sorts of directions. It can amplify our emotions and pump us up as Journey did. It can calm our emotions and pump us up as Journey did. It can calm us down. Sometimes I now will strategically use music
或避开这些类型的刺激或体验。因此，感知和情绪是紧密相连的。我的意思是，我们可以顺着这个清单往下数。我们刚刚谈到了音乐。音乐可以将我们的情绪推向各种方向。它可以放大我们的情绪并让我们振奋起来，就像《别放弃》所做的那样。它可以让我们平静下来。有时我现在会战略性地使用音乐
if I find myself too animated before a presentation or important interview, I will listen to calming music. We can also listen to music to push us in the negative direction as we sometimes do when we're not feeling great. We lean into those emotions even further by listening to ballads, love ballads if you will. Vision, art, attractiveness, smell. Let's talk about smell for a second. Smell is a really interesting one. Scent elicits emotions. So I remember when my daughters
——如果我发现自己在做演讲或重要面试前过于激动，我会听平静的音乐。我们也可以听音乐来将我们推向消极的方向，就像我们在感觉不太好时有时会做的那样。我们通过听情歌（如果你愿意的话，悲伤的情歌）进一步沉溺于这些情绪中。视觉、艺术、吸引力、嗅觉。我们来谈谈嗅觉。嗅觉是一个非常有趣的感官。气味会唤起情绪。所以，我记得当我的女儿们
were younger on vacation we'd go to a hotel and inevitably the hotel would smell really wonderful in the lobby. And I remember seeing on their face this expression of blissfulness and they'd go, Daddy, it smells so good in here. I love this place. And so what was happening there is those hotels were piping sense through their ventilation systems to arouse a kind of positive emotional response
还小的时候，在假期里我们会去一家酒店，不可避免地酒店大堂里会弥漫着非常美妙的香味。我记得在她们脸上看到了那种幸福的表情，她们会说：“爸爸，这里面闻起来太香了。我喜欢这个地方。”所以当时发生的情况是，那些酒店通过通风系统散发气味，以激起客人们和访客的一种积极情绪反应。
among the guests and visitors of the hotel. So these are shifters, these are levers that you can pull and they're really, really reliable movers of emotion. I will do an exercise when I'm teaching about this topic in my classes where I will have people rate how they're feeling throughout the class. I'll get a baseline reading of how they're feeling after I've taught for 20 or 30 minutes. And then I'll give the first sensory experience. Unbeknownst to them, I'll have pizza delivered into the class
所以这些都是情绪的塑造者，是你可以拉动的杠杆，它们是非常非常可靠的情绪推动器。当我在课堂上讲授这个主题时，我会做一个练习，让人们在整个课程中对自己的感觉进行评分。我会获得他们感觉的基线读数，在我讲课20或30分钟之后。然后我会给出第一个感官体验。在他们不知情的情况下，我会让外卖员把披萨送到教室里，
and I'll ask them to just take a bite of the pizza and taste it. And then I'll have them rate their emotions again. And you see this ginormous improvement in how they're feeling. They're almost at ceiling on the scale. Then I'll put on a scene from a Pixar movie where a character falls in love and then gets old and their wife dies and then I have them rate their emotions again.
并让他们咬一口披萨并品尝它。然后我会让他们再次给自己的情绪评分。你会看到他们的感觉有了巨大的改善。他们在量表上几乎达到了最高点。然后我会播放皮克斯电影中的一个片段，讲的是一个角色坠入爱河然后变老、妻子去世，接着我让他们再次给情绪评分。
And you see the emotions go down. Then I give them one final experience. And I do a little bit more lecturing. Then I play the fight song for the University of Michigan, which is our kind of rallying cry. ["Rallying Cry"] And this is my favorite moment in the class because I play this song and then I look around and I see students who have never uttered a word in class.
你会看到情绪下降了。然后我给他们最后的体验。我做了一点更多的讲课。然后我播放密歇根大学的战歌，这是我们的精神口号。[《精神口号》] 这是我在课堂上最喜欢的时刻，因为我播放这首歌，然后环顾四周，看到那些在课堂上从未说过一句话的学生。
Their eyes are closed, they start bopping their head just like Danny did in the car that day, and then they start like getting even more aggressive with the head bopping. Some are singing along, and then they rate their emotions again, their positive emotions, and they're back up to where the pizza was. So I'm essentially triggering different levels of positive and negative emotion like a symphony orchestra conductor based on my understanding of how the senses impact the way people feel, the opportunity here for everyone is to think about how can you trigger your senses
他们闭上眼睛，开始像那天在车里的丹妮一样晃脑袋，然后他们开始更激烈地晃脑袋。有些人跟着唱，然后他们再次给自己的情绪评分，他们的积极情绪又回到了披萨所在的高位。因此，基于我对感官如何影响人们感觉的理解，我本质上就像交响乐团的指挥一样触发着不同程度的积极和消极情绪，这里对每个人的机遇在于思考：你如何以健康的方式触发你的感官，从而带来你所期望的情感结果？
in a healthy way to bring about the emotional outcomes that you desire. When it comes to emotion regulation, it turns out there is no one way to do it that works for everyone. Different people find different techniques effective. In fact, what works for you one day might not work for you the next day. When we come back, why trying lots of different emotion regulation techniques is a good idea and a look at some of the more surprising ways to harness our feelings. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
谈到情绪调节，事实并没有哪一种方法对所有人都管用。不同的人发现不同的技术有效。事实上，今天对你管用的方法明天可能就不管用了。广告回来后，为什么尝试各种不同的情绪调节技术是个好主意，以及看看一些利用我们感受的更令人惊讶的方法。你正在收听的是“隐藏的大脑”。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。
This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedanta. There are times when we feel a surge of emotion in the moment and we have to find ways to regulate our feelings in order to function effectively. But there are other times when we do just fine in the moment but can't stop intrusive thoughts from entering our heads in the weeks and months afterwards. Grief can do this to people, so can worry. Psychologist Ethan Cross is the author of Shift, Managing Your Emotions So They Don't Manage You. Ethan, you've written about the experience of a woman you call Louisa,
这里是隐藏的大脑。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。有时我们在当下会感到情绪涌动，必须找到方法来调节我们的感受，以便有效地运作。但有时我们在当下做得很好，却无法阻止侵入性的想法在接下来的几周和几个月里进入我们的脑海。悲伤会给人们带来这种情况，担忧也是如此。心理学家伊森·克罗斯是《转移：管理你的情绪，别让情绪管理你》一书的作者。伊森，你写过一个女人的经历，你称她为路易莎，
who dealt with a very scary situation involving her little daughter. Tell me what happened. So the scene is one that you've likely encountered countless times. You're on a plane and you see a mom sitting with their little child and they're at 30,000 feet and the kid takes a bite of a granola bar and then begins to cough. And immediately the mom, named Louisa, reaches over to look at the granola bar wrapper and there it is. She missed it. She sees on the ingredient list peanuts.
她经历了一个涉及她小女儿的非常可怕的情况。告诉我发生了什么。当时的场景你很可能遇到过无数次。你在一架飞机上，看到一位妈妈和她的小孩子坐在一起，飞机飞行在3万英尺的高空，孩子咬了一口燕麦能量棒，然后开始咳嗽。这位名叫路易莎的妈妈立即探过身去查看能量棒包装纸，结果赫然发现。她漏掉了。她在配料表上看到了花生。
And the kid has a pretty severe peanut allergy. has a pretty severe peanut allergy. The first thing she does is she whips out some Benadryl from her bag and gives her kid a dose of Benadryl, but it doesn't have the intended effect. And so the daughter starts to writhe in pain, her stomach hurts, she begins to vomit. So she has to take the more extreme measure of reaching in her bag for the EpiPen, pulls down her daughter's pajamas, and jams the pen into her thigh. Fortunately the intervention does this time have the intended effect and the allergic reaction subsides The emotional reaction that Louisa struggled with after this flight persisted for months
而这个孩子对花生有相当严重的过敏反应。她做的第一件事是从包里掏出一些苯海拉明给孩子喂了一剂，但它没有产生预期的效果。于是女儿开始痛苦地蜷缩着身子，胃痛，开始呕吐。所以她不得不采取更极端的措施，把手伸进包里拿EpiPen（肾上腺素自动注射笔），拉下女儿的睡衣，把注射笔扎进她的女儿大腿里。幸运的是，这次干预确实产生了预期的效果，过敏反应消退了。路易莎在这次飞行后苦苦挣扎的情绪反应持续了数月之久。
She couldn't stop thinking about what if stop thinking about what if on the one hand going back in time what if she hadn't had the EpiPen? What if the EpiPen didn't work? Then she'd go into the future and she would do the same thing. What if another kid at school gives her daughter a taste of his or her snack and it has peanuts. What if her daughter goes to a birthday party and another parent unwittingly serves her a piece of cake that was prepared in a kitchen with peanuts and these thoughts, these intrusive thoughts begin to metastasize in her mind and are becoming unbelievably disruptive.
她无法停止去想“如果”……如果时光倒流，如果她没有EpiPen怎么办？如果EpiPen不起作用怎么办？然后她的思绪会延伸到未来，她会做同样的事情。如果学校里的另一个孩子让她的女儿尝了一口零食，而零食里有花生怎么办？如果她的女儿去参加生日派对，另一个父母不知情地端给她一块在带有花生的厨房里准备的蛋糕怎么办？这些想法，这些侵入性的想法开始在她的脑海中不断滋生，变得令人难以置信地具有破坏性。
Did she find a way to get a handle on them, Ethan? She did. So several months later, she had begun to spin into one of these thought spirals and her daughter actually came in, distracted her, and she realized that she began to feel better. She then had the insight that, wait a second, if I divert my attention away and I don't do what I want to do, what I desperately want to do, which is engage in these what if scenarios. If I resist the temptation to do that and I focus on something else entirely, then I actually feel a lot better. Some people might say that Louisa was distracting herself, Ethan. Is that right? Is that healthy? There's a giant myth that avoidance is always harmful.
她找到办法控制它们了吗，伊森？找到了。所以在几个月后，她开始陷入其中一种思维漩涡，这时她的女儿走了进来，分散了她的注意力，她意识到自己开始感觉好多了。然后她顿悟了，等等，如果我转移注意力，不做我想做的事，不做我极度渴望做的事——也就是陷入这些“如果……会怎样”的情景中。如果我抵制住这样做的诱惑，把注意力完全集中在别的事情上，那么我其实会感觉好很多。有些人可能会说露易莎是在转移自己的注意力，伊森。是这样吗？这健康吗？有一种巨大的迷思，认为逃避总是无益的。
And I think we need to correct that myth because the ability to strategically deploy your attention away from things at times can actually be really useful. There's no question that chronically avoiding things is not good. But in Luis's case, taking time away from the experience often just let that experience fizzle altogether. I've experienced this in my life many times before, and I should say Shankar that sometimes I can get triggered by an email, a conversation, a thought, and then if I force myself to take some time away from it, the experience ceases to bother me
我认为我们需要纠正这个迷思，因为有时能够战略性地将注意力从某些事情上转移开，其实真的非常有用。毫无疑问，长期逃避事情是不好的。但在路易斯的例子中，花时间脱离这种体验，往往能让这种体验彻底烟消云散。我在生活中经历过很多次这种情况，我得说，尚卡尔，有时我会被一封电子邮件、一段对话、一个想法所触发，然后如果我强迫自己花点时间远离它，这种体验就会不再困扰我
at all or sometimes when I come back to the problem after taking some time away, I find that the problem has tempered quite a bit and it's a lot easier for me to deal with the problem objectively and effectively. So growing up Ethan, you were able to observe the strategy of selective avoidance in someone who was very close to you. How did your grandmother handle the devastating experiences she had been through as a younger person?
分毫；或者有时我在花时间远离之后再回过头来处理这个问题，我发现问题已经缓和了很多，我能够更客观、更有效地处理这个问题了。所以，伊森，你在成长过程中，能够从一个与你非常亲近的人身上观察到这种选择性逃避的策略。你的祖母是如何应对她年轻时经历过的那些毁灭性遭遇的呢？
So my grandmother was a hero of mine. I spent almost every afternoon at her house growing up after school. While my parents were working, she took care of me. And her backstory was a really interesting one. So she was born and was raised in Eastern Europe in Poland and witnessed her family be slaughtered by the Nazis during World War II.
所以，我的祖母是我的英雄。我成长过程中，几乎每天下午放学后都会在她家度过。在我父母工作的时候，她照顾我。她的过去非常有趣。她出生并在东欧的波兰长大，在二战期间亲眼目睹了她的家人被纳粹屠杀。
And she then basically fled the Nazis, lived in the forest for years as she tried to survive with my grandfather. And growing up, I would always want to hear about the stories that she experienced, but she would never talk to me about them. Except one time a year, there would be this Remembrance Day that she and other members of her community from Eastern Europe, the survivors, would organize this day. And I would just listen to my grandmother
后来她基本上逃离了纳粹，为了和我的祖父一起活下去，在森林里生活了多年。在我成长过程中，我总是想听她经历的故事，但她从不跟我谈起。除了每年有一天，会有这样一个纪念日，她和她来自东欧的社区里的其他成员、那些幸存者们会组织这一天。而我就会听着我的祖母
and grandfather and others just wail. They would talk in detail about what they went through. They would say things and tell stories that I would never hear on any other day except that one day. And then the day was over and she would go back to being her more stoic self when it came to these experiences. And so what I later realized is what my grandmother was doing is she was being strategic in terms of allowing herself to think about what she went through and her family members who perished selectively though and on her terms. And that was a solution that worked well for her. And it's a solution that flies in the face of, I think, lots of popular calls to always approach her emotions.
、祖父和其他人放声痛哭。他们会详细谈论他们的经历。他们会说出一些话，讲一些我在除了那一天之外的任何其他日子都听不到的故事。然后这一天结束了，在面对这些经历时，她又会恢复成她那种更加坚忍的自我。所以我后来意识到，我祖母所做的是，她在策略性地允许自己去思考她的经历以及那些遇难的家属，但这是有选择性的，而且是按照她自己的条件来的。这是一个对她很有效的解决方案。我认为，这个解决方案公然违背了许多关于“永远要面对自己的情绪”的流行呼吁。
We now know from research that some people benefit from not reflexively approaching their emotions. And sometimes this capacity to be strategic in how you deploy your attention can actually be really really effective. So it seems like what she was doing was compartmentalizing her emotions. She was saying that now is a time to basically engage in them, soak in them, share them and there are other times when I'm gonna hold it in. That's right and by all accounts she led a great life And so this was a tool that worked well for her. It reminds me of some of the data surrounding how people coped following the 9-11 attacks.
我们现在从研究中了解到，有些人从不本能地面对自己的情绪中受益。有时，这种在部署注意力时保持战略性的能力，实际上可以非常非常有效。所以看起来她所做的是将她的情绪进行区块化管理。她是在说，现在是基本上投入其中、沉浸其中、分享这些情绪的时候了，而有些时候我会把它压在心底。没错，从各方面来看，她都过着非常棒的生活，所以这是一个对她很有效的工具。这让我想起了一些围绕人们在9·11袭击后如何应对的数据。
So I was living in New York. I had just moved to graduate school actually, a week or two before the plane struck the Twin Towers. And I remember in the immediate aftermath of those attacks, there was a lot of discourse about the need to care for the people in New York City, and in particular the people living around, living and working around ground zero. And there was this assumption that we have to get them to talk about their feelings. We've got to force them to really like just get it all out. Don't keep it bowed up
当时我住在纽约。飞机撞击双子塔前的一个星期左右，我刚搬去读研究生。我记得在那些袭击发生的直接余波中，有很多关于需要照顾纽约市人民的讨论，特别是住在世贸中心归零地（Ground Zero）周围、在周围居住和工作的人。当时有一种假设，认为我们必须让他们谈论自己的感受。我们必须强迫他们真正地把一切都倾吐出来。不要把它憋在
inside. Fast forward several years, there have been studies which have tracked people's tendencies to talk about what they experienced during the 9-11 attacks over time. And what the data show is that in some cases, talking about what people went through actually didn't have any effect on their emotional experience, and in some cases, it actually made them feel worse. And so if there's one big take home that I have learned over the past 25 years of doing research in this space, it is that there are no one size fits all solutions
心里。快进到几年后，有一些研究追踪了人们随着时间推移谈论其在9·11袭击中经历的倾向。数据表明，在某些情况下，谈论人们经历的事情实际上对他们的情感体验没有任何影响，而在某些情况下，它实际上让他们感觉更糟。因此，如果说我在过去25年从事这个领域的研究所学到的最重要的一个经验，那就是没有放之四海皆准的解决方案
when it comes to managing our emotional lives. Some people benefit enormously from talking to other people about their experiences and processing and working through them. I happen to be someone like that. I do tend to like to work through the experiences when it occurred. Other people don't avail themselves of that tool
来管理我们的情感生活。有些人从与他人谈论自己的经历、加工和处理这些经历中获益匪浅。我恰好就是这样的人。当经历发生时，我确实倾向于去处理它们。其他人并没有利用这个工具
and they do different things instead. We have access to a vast armamentarium of tools that we can wield and as you mentioned earlier in our conversation, different strokes for different folks. Another approach to emotion that psychologists and ordinary people have often assumed is unhealthy is what we might call acting out, letting loose with behavior that's unusual or unconventional. You cite the story of a famous Chicago athlete who went to some lengths to act out, even
，而是做了别的事情。我们可以使用庞大的工具库，正如你在我们对话早些时候提到的那样，萝卜青菜，各有所爱。心理学家和普通人经常认为不健康的另一种对待情绪的方法，就是我们可能称之为“发泄”（acting out）的行为——做出不寻常或非传统的行为来释放自己。你提到了一个芝加哥著名运动员的故事，他竭尽全力去发泄，甚至
as his team was on the pinnacle of accomplishing great feats. Tell me that story, Ethan. So this is a story about Dennis Rodman when he's playing with the Bulls and they're vying for another championship. And there's a break between games. And rather than just taking it easy, maybe joining the team for a light practice. He takes off, goes to Detroit, participates in a wrestling match. Oh my goodness, that was Rodman! And then comes back, rejoins his team, and has one of the best games of his career, or that season one of his best games, and they ultimately win the championship yet again. my interpretation of Rodman's behavior there is he's doing something not that different from what my grandmother did in the sense that he's in this very high pressure situation, right? Like
在他们球队处于取得伟大功绩的巅峰时刻也是如此。给我讲讲那个故事吧，伊森。这是一个关于丹尼斯·罗德曼的故事，当时他正效力于公牛队，他们正争夺另一个总冠军。比赛之间有一段间歇。他没有选择轻松对待、或许加入球队进行轻松的训练，而是离开去到底特律，参加了一场摔跤比赛。哦天哪，那是罗德曼！然后他回来，重新加入他的球队，打出了他职业生涯或是那个赛季最好的比赛之一，他们最终再次赢得了总冠军。我对罗德曼当时行为的解读是，他做的事和我祖母做的事并没有太大区别，因为他正处于这个压力极大的处境中，对吧？比如
playing for a championship at the highest levels with the most elite athletes in the world. And he's totally diverting his attention by going into a totally different context for a short period to essentially restore and then comes back fresh. This is a form of avoiding. It's an avoidance behavior. Now I want to be really clear. There are some kinds of avoidance behaviors that are harmful across the board. Drug usage, risky sexual behavior. These have been definitively shown to not be helpful for people's lives. That's not what we're talking about.
在最高水平上与世界上最精英的运动员一起为冠军而战。他通过短时间内进入一个完全不同的环境来彻底转移注意力，本质上是为了恢复精力，然后以崭新的状态回来。这是一种逃避的形式。这是一种逃避行为。现在我想说清楚。有些逃避行为是全面有害的。吸毒、危险的性行为。这些已经被明确证明对人们的生活没有帮助。这不是我们在谈论的。
When I talk about strategic avoidance, I mean temporarily diverting your attention, shift your attentional spotlight, let the other problem simmer down so that when you return to it, if you return to it at all, if you need to return to it, you can do so from a more objective and restored point of view.
当我谈到战略性逃避时，我的意思是暂时转移你的注意力，改变你的注意力焦点，让其他问题沉淀下来，这样当你回归它时——如果你还要回归它的话，如果你需要回归它的话——你可以从一个更客观、更有恢复力的角度来处理。
Talk about why using a variety of emotion regulation strategies might be better than using only one or two. Why would this be the case, Ethan? Research in the space of emotion regulation began with researchers identifying specific tools and then carefully profiling how they work mechanistically across levels of analysis and in different groups. And so we've done that with lots of individual tools and we have identified dozens. What research has yet to do though is understand how different tools combine to help people
谈谈为什么使用多种情绪调节策略可能比只使用一两种更好。为什么会这样呢，伊森？情绪调节领域的研究始于研究人员确定具体的工具，然后仔细剖析它们在各个分析层面以及不同群体中是如何通过机制起作用的。我们对许多单独的工具都做了这些工作，已经识别出了几十种。然而，研究尚未做到的是，了解不同的工具是如何组合起来帮助人们
dealing with different situations that they encounter in their lives. What we know is that when you look at how people manage their emotions in their daily lives they don't restrict themselves to just one tool. On average we find that people use between three and four strategies each day to manage that experience. And so so we know that people are using multiple tools. And we also know that different combinations of tools are working for different people, right? It's not just one combination. We don't yet know why certain tools hang together for certain people. The metaphor
应对他们在生活中遇到的不同情况的。我们所知道的是，当你观察人们在日常生活中如何管理自己的情绪时，他们并不局限于单一的工具。平均而言，我们发现人们每天使用三到四种策略来管理这种体验。所以我们知道人们在使用多种工具。我们也知道不同的工具组合对不同的人都有效，对吧？不只是某一种组合。我们还不知道为什么某些工具会因为某些特定的人而结合在一起。我在这里喜欢用的比喻
I like to use here to make sense of this, which really resonates strongly with me is to, is to look to physical fitness and exercise. When you go to the gym, number one, you don't do one exercise. If you, if you're, if you're weight training, for example, I haven't met anyone who only curls biceps as the only thing they do in the gym, right? You do a few different things and you actually, you switch up the exercises every single day to meet different kinds of physical
来理解这一点，它真的引起了我的强烈共鸣，那就是去看看身体健康和锻炼。当你去健身房时，首先，你不会只做一个锻炼。如果你，如果你是，如果你在进行力量训练，例如，我没有见过谁在健身房里唯一的锻炼就是二头肌弯举，对吧？你会做几种不同的事情，而且实际上，你每天都会变换不同的练习，以适应你不同的体能
demands that you have, physical goals. We also know that different people avail themselves of different physical fitness regimens, so I may lift weights and run and do some high intensity interval training. My wife does Pilates and yoga. Pilates and yoga works really well for my wife. And what I do works really well for me. So we use multiple tools and different people use different kinds of tools. I think that actually scaffolds really nicely onto what we're learning about how to be emotionally fit.
需求、健身目标。我们也知道，不同的人会利用不同的健身方案，所以我可能会举重、跑步并做一些高强度间歇训练。我妻子做普拉提和瑜伽。普拉提和瑜伽对我妻子非常有效。而我做的事对我也非常有效。所以我们使用多种工具，不同的人使用不同种类的工具。我认为这实际上与我们正在了解的如何保持情感健康非常吻合。
I'm wondering if this is something that you yourself consciously do, Ethan. Do you find yourself reaching for different tools in the toolkits to regulate your own emotions? I do. I'm incredibly deliberate about the tools I use and I have, I have, it's not haphazard for me, so I have different layers of intervention. So my initial intervention is I use distant self-talk and mental time travel. Those are my first two go-tos. Sometimes I'll throw in creating order around me.
我想知道这是否是你自己会有意识去做的事情，伊森。你发现自己会伸手去拿工具箱里的不同工具来调节自己的情绪吗？是的。我对使用的工具有着难以置信的刻意规划，我有，我有——对我来说这不是随意的，我有不同层面的干预。所以我的初步干预是使用远距离自言自语和心理时间旅行。这是我的前两个首选。有时我会加入“在周围创造秩序”。
So we know when emotions are feeling really big and out of control, we don't feel like we have order in our minds. Creating order around us compensates for that experience. So I'll do those two or three things. Sometimes though, it's not enough. And I have to ratchet it up and go to another layer of intervention.
所以我们知道，当情绪感觉非常巨大且失控时，我们会觉得自己的内心失去了秩序。在我们周围创造秩序可以弥补这种体验。所以我通常会做这两三件事。不过有时，这还不够。我必须升级并进入另一个干预层面。
What I'll do in that point is I'll call some of my emotional advisors up what I mean by emotional advisors These are not clinically trained individuals. I'm not paying them for support These are people in my network who do two things for me number one. They're really adept at Connecting with me emotionally they empath, they validate what I'm going through. There's a resonance that I don't have to worry about being created. And then after that kind of emotional connection is achieved and they learn about what I'm going through,
在那一点上我会做的是，我会给我的情绪顾问打电话——我所说的情绪顾问是什么意思？这些不是受过临床训练的人。我不是付钱让他们提供支持。这些是我网络中的人，他们为我做两件事。第一，他们非常擅长与我在情感上建立连接，他们有同理心，他们肯定我正在经历的事情。有一种共鸣，让我不必担心这种连接无法建立。然后在达成这种情感连接、他们了解了我正在经历的事情之后，
they help me work through the experience. So that'll be the second line of intervention. I'll sometimes often, this is weather permitting in the state in which I live in Michigan, I'll go for a walk in our arboretum or down certain tree-lined streets in our neighborhood. I've been really, really impressed by the data demonstrating how restorative and regulating going for a walk in a safe, natural setting can be. And so I'll layer that in as well.
他们会帮我梳理这段经历。这就是第二道干预防线。我有时会——如果我所居住的密歇根州天气允许的话——去我们的植物园散步，或者沿着我们社区里某些林荫街道散步。数据表明，在安全、自然的环境中散步具有多么强的恢复和调节作用，这让我留下了非常非常深刻的印象。所以我也会把这个纳入其中。
And, you know, 90% of the time, that's what I need to do to break out of my funk. When we come back, an emotion regulation strategy to deploy when all the others fail. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedant. Emotion Regulation Strategy to Deploy When All the Others Fail. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Many of us dream of fame and success. We imagine that when we have those things,
而且，你知道，90%的时间里，这就是我摆脱沮丧情绪所需要做的事情。当我们回来时，将介绍一种在所有其他方法都失效时可部署的情绪调节策略。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。一种在所有其他方法都失效时可部署的情绪调节策略。您正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。我们许多人梦想着名誉和成功。我们想象着当我们拥有这些东西时，
our lives will be happy and fulfilled. Psychologist Ethan Cross tells the story of a person who stumbled into fame and success and found they didn't have the effects on her emotions that she expected. Ethan, some time ago we featured the Yale psychologist Laurie Santos on Hidden Brain, and she was a very successful psychologist. and found they didn't have the effects on her emotions that she expected. Ethan, some time ago we featured the Yale psychologist Laurie Santos on Hidden Brain.
我们的生活将会幸福美满。心理学家伊森·克罗斯讲述了一个偶然获得名誉和成功的人的故事，她发现这些并没有对她的情绪产生她所期望的影响。伊森，不久前我们在《隐藏的大脑》中邀请了耶鲁大学心理学家劳里·桑托斯，她是一位非常成功的心理学家。并发现这些并没有对她的情绪产生她所期望的影响。伊森，不久前我们在《隐藏的大脑》中邀请了耶鲁大学心理学家劳里·桑托斯。
She talked about some of her early research on animal behavior. We published an episode about her work. Listeners who are interested can go to hiddenbrain.org and look up the episode titled, The Monkey Marketplace. This was in 2019. What I wasn't aware of, Ethan, is that Laurie's life had recently been upended. What happened?
她谈到了她早期关于动物行为的一些研究。我们发布了一期关于她工作的节目。感兴趣的听众可以访问 hiddenbrain.org，查找标题为《猴子市场》（The Monkey Marketplace）的节目。这是在2019年。伊森，我当时不知道的是，劳里的生活最近被颠覆了。发生了什么？
Well, Laurie had just taken over duties as the head of one of Yale's colleges, where she effectively acted as a type of den mother to the undergrads. She was there to not just make sure the dorm was kept in order, to also be a type of mentor-like figure for the students. And while acting in that capacity, she noticed about the struggles, the everyday kinds of struggles they were often encountering. And so she very
嗯，劳里刚刚接任耶鲁大学一个书院（college）的院长职务，在那里她实际上充当了本科生们的“大家长”角色。她呆在那里不仅是为了确保宿舍保持井然有序，也是为了成为学生们的导师般的人物。在履行这一职责时，她注意到了学生们所面临的挣扎，即他们经常遇到的日常各种挣扎。所以她非常
creatively decided to teach a course on the topic of how to have a good life and What she didn't expect was that once enrollment for the course was open That a record number of students would sign up for it. I believe the number was over 900 Wow She quickly catapulted from a professor with an excellent reputation on campus to a veritable superstar. And it wasn't just being a superstar on campus. Pretty soon, the New York Times and other periodicals caught wind of what she was doing and they started covering her. And so the next thing you know, she's giving lectures
有创意地决定开设一门关于如何过上好日子的课程。她没有料到的是，一旦这门课开放注册，就会有创纪录数量的学生报名。我相信人数超过了900人。哇！她迅速从校园里享有盛誉的教授跃升为真正的超级巨星。而且不仅是在校园里成为超级巨星。很快，《纽约时报》和其他期刊注意到了她正在做的事情，并开始报道她。所以接下来你知道的，她开始做讲座
and then flying out to do interviews and give talks elsewhere. At one point, she's so busy that an invitation comes in to literally meet with the Pope that she had to turn down, just to put in perspective how much her life had changed. And from the outside looking in, it would seem like everything is going so unbelievably well for Lori. That was certainly the impression that I had from afar as a friend of hers who was just proud of her and relishing her successes. What I didn't realize at the time
，然后飞去各处接受采访和发表演讲。有一段时间，她忙得甚至收到了一个邀请，字面意思是去面见教皇，她不得不拒绝，这可以让人客观地看待她的生活发生了多么巨大的变化。从局外人的角度来看，似乎一切对劳里来说都好得不可思议。作为一个为她感到骄傲并享受她的成功的她的朋友，我从远处看确实有这种印象。我当时没有意识到的是，
and what you didn't realize either when you interviewed her was that Lori was really struggling because with this new fame came all of these demands and Lori is such a helper. She wants to help everyone and these requests were coming in from all over the place and she just found herself totally overworked and totally burnt out.
而且你在采访她时也没有意识到的是，劳里当时真的在苦苦挣扎，因为随着这种新名气而来的是所有这些要求，而劳里是一个如此乐于助人的人。她想帮助每一个人，这些请求从四面八方涌来，她发现自己彻底过度劳累并且完全精疲力竭。
She had also began to record a podcast, The Happiness Lab, which very quickly ascended the ranks of popularity in the podcast world. And so she had a gazillion things going on. And she was teaching students about the tools, about many tools that they can use to be happier and lead more successful lives. And it goes back to this, this finding about how we are, we're much better at giving advice to others and sometimes implementing that advice on our own. And I don't think that discounts the advice we give in any way. The advice we give, the counsel we offer to others is sometimes enormously helpful. But there are some impediments that we sometimes experience when we try to apply that advice to ourselves.
她还开始录制一个播客《幸福实验室》（The Happiness Lab），该播客在播客世界的受欢迎程度迅速攀升。所以她有一大堆事情在同时进行。她在教导学生们关于如何变得更快乐、过上更成功生活的各种工具，许多可以使用的工具。这就回到了这个发现，即我们更擅长给别人出谋划策，而有时却很难将这些建议落实到自己身上。我不认为这在任何方面贬低了我们给出的建议。我们给出的建议、我们为他人提供的指导有时具有巨大的帮助。但当我们试图将这些建议应用到自己身上时，有时会遇到一些障碍。
At one point, Laurie was recording a podcast episode, and again, she's like this hamster, you know, juggling different things and trying to keep all the different balls in the air. And during this podcast interview, she finds that she has basically been pronouncing a guest's name wrong throughout the recording. What happens, Ethan? She slams her keyboard in frustration and and
有一次，劳里正在录制一期播客节目，再次强调，她就像这只仓鼠一样，你知道的， juggling（兼顾）不同的事情，试图让所有的球都在空中旋转。在这次播客采访中，她发现自己在整个录音过程中基本上把一个嘉宾的名字读错了。发生了什么，伊森？她气愤地猛砸键盘，并且
breaks it and and then sheepishly has to go into tech to get it fixed. It's a very human experience. Sometimes we reach our breaking points and this is true of the experts as well. And she had reached her breaking point. You also tell the story about a time when she received a relatively benign request from a student who was looking for help in terms of a dental emergency. Can you tell me that story, Ethan? So this was a real turning point for Lori where she realized she had to do something different. A student emails her with this benign question. He or she is looking for dental resources. They need a dentist. She is by very nature someone who likes to help others.
把它砸坏了，然后只好羞怯地去找技术人员来修理。这是非常人性化的体验。有时我们会到达崩溃的边缘，专家也是如此。她已经达到了崩溃的边缘。你还讲述了一个故事，当时她收到了一个相对良性的请求，来自一个寻求牙科紧急情况帮助的学生。你能给我讲讲那个故事吗，伊森？所以这是劳里真正的一个转折点，她意识到自己必须做点不同的事情了。一个学生发电子邮件提出了这个良性的问题。他或她正在寻找牙科资源。他们需要一个牙医。她天生就是一个喜欢帮助别人的人。
She took this position as being the head of a college because she liked to help others. And this request comes in for some help. And rather than instantly trying to share resources with the student and get them the information they that they need. Instead she immediately experiences irritation and anger and frustration. Oh one more thing I have to deal with. I don't have time to deal with this. Those thoughts and the accompanying feelings were elicited automatically and and actually she was embarrassed that she had even entertained those thoughts. But it was that experience that really signaled to Lori
她接受这个书院院长的职位就是因为她喜欢帮助别人。然后这个寻求帮助的请求进来了。她没有立即试着与学生分享资源并获取他们需要的信息，而是立即体验到了烦躁、愤怒和挫败感。“哦，又多了一件我要处理的事。我没时间处理这个。”这些想法以及伴随而来的情绪是自动产生的，而且实际上，她对自己的脑海中竟然闪过这些想法感到很尴尬。但正是这种经历真正向劳里发出了信号，
that she had to do something. So she's a psychologist, she's a researcher, she had tried lots of things, she had talked to people, she was seeing a therapist, she had tried journaling. None of these techniques had worked, so what did she do? She left. So she put in for an unpaid leave and she essentially took a sabbatical. She moved to another college town and she settled there and the moment she changed her space, she found that she was overcome with a sense of emotional relief.
她必须做点什么了。所以她是一名心理学家，她是一名研究人员，她尝试过很多方法，她和人谈过，她在看心理医生，她尝试过写日记。这些技术没有一个管用，所以她做了什么？她离开了。所以她申请了无薪休假，基本上休了学术假。她搬到了另一个大学镇并在那里定居，就在她改变空间的那一刻，她发现自己被一种情绪上的解脱感淹没了。
I find this really interesting because I think it's easy to underestimate the role that our environment, our physical environment plays in our emotional life. And in fact, our environment contains resources that we can use to manage our emotions if we understand where to find them. So we often talk about attachment. I'm sure you've had many scholars on the show talking about the attachments we form to other people and the role they play in our emotional lives. People that we are securely attached with, positively attached to, they can provide a real source of resilience during
我觉得这非常有趣，因为我认为人们很容易低估环境——我们的物理环境——在我们的情感生活中扮演的角色。事实上，我们的环境包含着我们可以用来管理情绪的资源，如果我们知道去哪里找它们的话。所以我们经常谈论依恋。我相信你的节目邀请过许多学者来谈论我们与其他人的依恋以及它们在我们的情感生活中扮演的角色。我们与之安全依恋、积极依恋的人，可以在
stressful times. Research shows that we also develop attachments to places. So there are places that we are positively connected with. And when we visit those spaces, they elicit a positive emotional response. I used to see this a lot with my daughters when they were little. I remember this was very striking. Whenever they would get really upset about something,
压力时期提供真正的韧性来源。研究表明，我们也会对地方产生依恋。所以有些地方是我们与之产生积极连接的。当我们访问这些空间时，它们会引发积极的情绪反应。我以前经常在我的女儿们很小的时候看到这种情况。我记得这非常引人注目。每当她们对某事感到非常沮丧时，
either a fight they had with someone at school, or maybe if they got in trouble with me or my wife, they would instantly say, I just wanna go home, I wanna go to my room. I wanna go to my room. Their room was a place that was a safe place for them, a sense of security. And they intuited this and when feeling down,
无论是在学校和别人打架，还是可能因为她们惹我和我妻子生气了，她们都会立刻说：“我只想回家，我想去我的房间。我想去我的房间。”她们的房间是一个对她们来说安全的地方，带有安全感。她们直觉到了这一点，当感到沮丧时，
wanted to visit it to regain that sense of security. And so I think it's really instructive to stop and think about what are the places in our lives that are the equivalent of safe houses when we are struggling with emotional problems. So I love watching these spy movies where you know the spy is being chased or the Jason Bourne character and there are safe houses embedded among the cities. We all have the equivalent of safe houses around us.
想要去那里重新获得这种安全感。所以我认为，停下来思考在我们与情绪问题作斗争时，生活中的哪些地方相当于“安全屋”，是非常有启发性的。我喜欢看那些间谍电影，你知道间谍正在被追捕，或者像杰森·伯恩那样的角色，城市里隐藏着安全屋。我们所有人的周围都有安全屋的等价物。
For me it's the Arboretum in Ann Arbor, a couple of blocks from my home. When I'm in that space, it has this very positive soothing effect. It's also the local tea house where I spent a significant amount of time writing my first book. I have very positive associations about that tea house
对我来说，安娜堡的植物园就是这样一个地方，离我家只有几个街区。当我身处那个空间时，它具有非常积极的抚慰效果。这也是当地的一家茶馆，我花了很多时间在那里写我的第一本书。我对那家茶馆有着非常积极的联想，
and simply sitting there fills me with a sense of comfort. And so that's another tool that people can use to manage their emotions. I understand that Laurie, stepping away from the stresses of her life in New Haven, she found this really restorative. She ended up giving up several of the things that she was doing.
仅仅坐在那里就充满了舒适感。所以这是人们用来管理情绪的另一个工具。据我了解，劳里离开纽黑文生活的压力后，她发现这真的很有恢复力。她最终放弃了她正在做的几件事情。
She surrendered some of her responsibilities, decisions that might have been much harder to make if she was still in New Haven. That's right, and so, switching spaces both provided her with a sense of comfort and resilience. It also acted as a type of distancing tool. In this case, it was a physical distancing tool. Getting the physical space away from the locus,
她放弃了部分责任——如果她还在纽黑文的话，这些决定可能要难得多。没错，所以，转换空间既为她提供了一种舒适感和韧性，也起到了一种距离工具的作用。在这种情况下，这是一个物理距离工具。获得远离焦点的物理空间，
from the location of the epicenter of the problem, allowed her to look at her circumstances from a wider point of view. She could see that bigger picture and she could see that maybe it's time to make some hard decisions about where to invest and where to divest. Ethan, you recently confronted a situation
远离问题震中所在的位置，使她能够从更广阔的视角审视自己的情况。她可以看到更大的图景，她可以看到也许是时候对把精力投资在哪里、从哪里撤资做出一些艰难的决定了。伊森，你最近面对了一个情况，
that called for all the emotion regulation skills you could muster. It began early one morning when your phone buzzed. Paint me a picture of what happened. A text message went off on my phone early in the morning and there was a message that said school for one of my daughters was being canceled that day. And I saw the message, it was very early on in the morning, and then I tried to go back to bed, but I wasn't very successful because my mind kept on trying to suss out
需要调动你能汇集的所有情绪调节技能。它开始于清晨，当时你的手机震动了。给我描绘一下当时发生了什么。清晨，我的手机上弹出了一个短信，上面说我其中一个女儿的学校那天取消上课。我看到了这条消息，那是很早的清晨，然后我试图重新入睡，但我不是很成功，因为我的大脑一直在试图弄清楚
why school was being canceled. Typically when we get text messages along these lines, the reason is given. Snow, really cold temperatures, et cetera. And so I kept on replaying it, and I ended up realizing that I wasn't getting back to bed, so I went downstairs. And a few minutes later,
为什么学校要停课。通常当我们收到这类短信时，会给出原因。大雪、极度寒冷等等。所以我一直在脑海中反复回放，最后我意识到我睡不着了，于是我下楼了。几分钟后，
I find out from a message from another parent that the reason school was being canceled was because a credible threat was made to the school, a threat to do really bad, harmful things. And this is a parent's worst nightmare, to have to entertain these kinds of possibilities. And the emails began to fly or the text messages back and forth between some of the other parents about what was going on and it was very easy to see tensions beginning to escalate. And the moment I began to notice myself beginning to spiral, I instantly implemented some of
我从另一位家长的消息中得知，学校停课的原因是有人对学校发出了可信的威胁，一个要做非常糟糕、有害事情的威胁。这是为人父母的噩梦，不得不去设想这些可能性。家长之间开始来来往往地飞发电子邮件或短信，讨论到底发生了什么，而且很容易看到紧张局势开始升级。就在我开始注意到自己开始陷入情绪漩涡的那一刻，我立刻实施了一些
the tools that we're talking about. The first thing I did is I broadened my perspective. I tried to look at the bigger picture here. I used distant self-talk to help me do it. I said to myself, the school and law enforcement agencies are investigating things. I don't have to worry about this right now. I also leaned into strategic avoidance. I recognized that there was nothing I could possibly do in this situation personally to resolve it. So I leaned
我们正在谈论的工具。我做的第一件事是拓宽我的视角。我试着在这里看更大的图景。我用远距离自言自语来帮助自己做到这一点。我对自己说：“学校和执法机构正在调查情况。我现在不用担心这个。”我还倾向于战略性避让。我认识到我在这个情况下个人无能为力去解决它。所以我全身心
hard into my work. I also went for a walk in the Arboretum near my house and that further helped me for a walk in the Arboretum near my house and that further helped me rest and restore. And I also tapped into my advisory board. I spoke to someone in my network who had some experience dealing with these kinds of circumstances and they were really helpful for further helping me look at that bigger picture and recognize the circumstances I was facing. Now engaging in those different tools did not make this problem go away. Fortunately it did go away. They caught the person who sent the thread and nothing bad happened. What using those tools allowed me to do is keep my anxiety about this issue at a reasonable level of activation.
投入到工作中。我还去我家附近的植物园散步，这进一步帮助我休息和恢复。我还联系了我的咨询委员会。我与我网络中的某个人谈过，他有一些处理这类情况的经验，他们对进一步帮助我看清大局并认识到我所面临的情况非常有帮助。现在，使用这些不同的工具并没有让这个问题凭空消失。幸运的是它确实消失了。他们抓住了发送威胁的人，什么坏事也没发生。使用这些工具让我做到的是将我对这件事的焦虑保持在一个合理的激活水平。
This was an important situation that I did want to be focused on and keeping eyes on. But what those tools allowed me to do was keep the emotions from metastasizing in ways that prevented me from doing anything else that day and feeling miserable as well. Ethan Cross is a psychologist at the University of Michigan. He's the author of Shift, Managing Your Emotions So They Don't Manage You. Ethan, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thanks. It was a joy as always, Shankar.
这是一个我确实想要关注和盯紧的重要情况。但那些工具让我做到的是，防止情绪以阻止我那天做任何其他事情以及感到痛苦的方式无限蔓延。伊森·克罗斯是密歇根大学的心理学家。他是《转变：管理你的情绪，别让情绪管理你》（Shift, Managing Your Emotions So They Don't Manage You）一书的作者。伊森，非常感谢你今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢。一如既往的高兴，尚卡尔。
Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Quirell, Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brains executive editor. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. Music There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《隐藏的大脑》由 Hidden Brain Media 制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保尔、克里斯滕·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、赖恩·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制作人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行主编。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。再见。音乐 本期节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可留下评论。